hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game also from the
penultimate round of this year's Norway
chess it is the Armageddon game between
another Becca and he called their
classical game of course ended with a
drawn and now they repeat the colors
only with different time format and make
no mistake this game was won by a
brilliant move uh and once you see what
happens after this move was played it
will not surprise you why uh one of the
players resigned the game uh very
quickly afterwards some uh two moves
after the the set move so let's check it
out Notre back has the white pieces and
he opens with E4 we're going to have a
pretty standard uh Berlin defense Knight
to C6 Bishop to B5 and now Knight to F6
the Berlin defense is on the board we
have castles and Knight captures on e4
yeah the Rio Gambit accepted Rook D1 and
Knight back to D6 it's all been seen
before of course not Knight captures an
E5 Bishop to E7 and now Bishop back to
F1 and here usually you will see Knight
Calpers and E5 but Hikaru wants to mix
it up he plays Knight to F5 which is the
second most popular continuation
although Knight captures an E5 is played
quite a bit more uh Knight back to F3 we
have castles and pawn to D4 now we have
Pawn to D5 and now Pawn to C3 with
Bishop to D6
uh and Knight beta D2 We have Knight
seat the E7 uh and now uh there is a
game that reached this exact same
position it was in the grenke chess
classic in 2017. uh hoi fan defeated
none other than Fabiano caruana they are
here with the white pieces she played
the Queen the C2 and won a very nice
game uh but another big was spawned A4
and it is now as of move 12 that we have
a completely new game it's okay Ponte
five of course he car knows that you can
just allow white to play B4 whenever
white pleases uh Bishop to D3 nicely
continuing development putting the
bishop on this long diagonal and pawn to
C6 strengthening the D5 Pawn Knight to
F1 Shifting the Knight over to G3 to put
more pressure on that F5 Knight and now
Pawn to G6 with Bishop to D2 and Knight
to G7 Knight F to G7 now we have Knight
the G3 and Knight E to F5 offering
trades on the F5 square but the white
doesn't really gain anything by training
trading and there's nothing worse than
uh trading for for the sake of just
Trading that you know we just don't do
that as chess players so Queen to B3
nicely developing uh and also putting
pressure on the B7 Pawn so the bishop
will have a hard time being developed
and also in the long run you might um
fight find some use along this diagram
we have Knight to H4 offering some trays
of pieces and we have a trade Knight
characters Queen captures and just
Knight back to F1 the Knight now guards
against Checkmate on H2 and also you
will play G3 kick away the queen so
Hikaru knows it's the best to bring the
queen back with Pawn to H3 and now
Knight the E6 with Bishop to H6
attacking the rook and The Rook the E8
and only Now Pawn to G3 uh Bishop to D7
by Hikaru and Knight to H2 now with
Bishop to f8 offering a trait of Bishops
and uh another big obliges captures
captures with the King we have Ponte H4
and now Queen to C7 so a pretty normal
position nothing really happening here
at some point another big will try to
execute H5 and it's a question whether
Hikaru will push his own Pawn to H5 to
prevent this or not here we have Knight
to F3 and now King back to G7 Knight the
E5 and now Bishop to C8 not allowing the
nice to have advantage over the bishop
here Queen back the C2 the queen doesn't
really have anything to do on B3 or on
C2 another week is just uh
re-maneuvering the queen over to D2 and
then you will find some use along the
dark squares here uh Pawn to C5 striking
in the center of course makes sense and
now Bishop to B5 puts pressure on The
Rook Rook the E7 and queen to D2 uh and
here Hikaru should definitely consider
upon the H5 you stop Pawn to H5 from
White and uh it's hard to find any any
good continuation here but he car played
Knight to f8 he probably even invited
Ponte H5 he wants another back to push
for the win uh and so he does spawn to
H5 with C4 now closing uh this Bishop's
path to return on on this long diagonal
and it's not really going to be all that
um of all that much use on B5 but that's
only what you would think here we have
Ponte H6 with check the absolute best
move by another king to Jade much better
than King the h8 because you go on a
dark square and then you have to worry
about Queen to F6 coming with the tempo
so King the G8 and now Queen the F4 by
by another by Queen the G5 would have
been much better because here you don't
have to worry about Bishop 5 blocking
your reach of the F6 square but even
Queen to F4 is perfectly fine uh point
is that it's uh incredibly difficult to
continue this game what you should do is
definitely play but of the F5 but even
this I will just show you a fun line
because it's it's also winning for white
Pawn to G4 you really want to get to
that F6 Square now Knight to E6 kicks
away your queen queen to F3 and now
Bishop to E4 you will go after the White
Queen Queen to F6 now uh preparing to
Checkmate the black king after the
Knight here is dealt with and after
Queen to d8 you will play Rook captures
on e4 that's how you reach the Knight
Pawn captures and now Pawn to D5 saying
you I removed the Knight and I Checkmate
you or you capture with the queen and
then look at this queen captures on D5
uh now comes the bishop Calpers on C4
and now you have to move the Queen
Bishop captures Knight and it's game
over so here basically you cannot
capture on D5 you have to play a slow
move like Rook to C7 but now okay a
queen trade is offered you simply trade
the queen captures You're Gonna Play
Knight captures and now Pawn to D6 and
even though uh black is up the exchange
it's a white who is completely winning
here due to the Past D Pawn so that's
how you win however after Queen to F4 a
Hikaru finds a beautiful defensive
resource that is spawn to F5 and this is
only bested by finding a a true
brilliancy of a move that another did
find so feel free to pause the video and
try to spot this idea while I give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this
incredible maneuver and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
night captures on C4 uh there are other
moves that of course will give you a
fine position like Queen to G5 Queen to
H4 or they're all very nice but Knight
captures on C4 it's just incredibly
forcing and just shows you that there is
nothing you can do and you don't uh have
all that many moves to consider here you
can capture the Knight you can capture
the queen or you can block with Bishop
to E6 and none of it really works uh the
the in the game Queen captures an F4 was
played I will just show you what happens
if you capture the Knight you've played
the captors and C4 then Bishop captures
on C4 with check and now how do you how
do you meet this move you can play
Bishop T6 you can play Queen captures
and C4 you can play King to h8 but none
of it works if you play King to h8 uh
just Queen captures on C7 Rook captures
and now this uh phenomenal Rook to E8
you are threatening Checkmate because
the pawn is covering G7 so even if the
The Rook captures the bishop open C4
Rook capture Center f8 will be Checkmate
the only way to avoid this is to move
the bishop let's Bishop to D7 you offer
a full Rook but then after Rook captures
an A8 you will play Bishop to C8 uh
close off the Rooks reach to the Knight
and now you are threatening to pick up
the bishop but just Bishop to B3 and
black is without a move whatever black
plays and there's really nothing you
can't play You're Gonna Go Rook D1 Rook
to E8 capture the Knight and Checkmate
the black king there is absolutely
nothing black can do about this because
the black king is just stuck there on h8
so that's what happens after Bishop
captures an um a C4 if you play King to
h8 another move of course is to capture
the uh bishop and C4 but now Rook
captures an E7 and okay you might think
okay I'm done the exchange maybe I can
play this uh no you can't uh you're not
even done the exchange you have you have
a bishop and Knight for a rook but you
are a dead lost because there's no
defense against Queen to E5 Queen to E5
and Checkmate and G7 that's it the only
way to take away uh the E5 Square from
White is Queen to D5 but then Pawn to C4
and now you can no longer keep an eye on
and the five square and also after
Bishop captures on C4 you could consider
Bishop to E6 but it just doesn't work
you can pretty much play anything here
you can capture then capture on C6 you
can capture on C6 first doesn't really
matter Bishop captures will come with
check you can play Knight captures Queen
captures and C7 are going to play Rook
captures and The Rook captures on E6 and
you are just up uh two Pawns in a
completely winning uh a rook end game so
that's the problem so that's why after
Knight captures on C4 Hikaru thought
alright let's trade Queens I I cannot
touch the Knight so Queen captures on F4
was played G captures on F4 and now
again you cannot touch the Knight
because the Rook on E7 is hanging so
Knight the E6 was played uh but now
another big just plays Knight to B6 here
Hikaru played Rook to B8 but also it was
in this position on move 36 uh after
making this move that Hikaru Nakamura
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here yes you do have
some material here but now you're also
going to lose the D5 pawn and that's
just unplayable Knight captures on D5
another big will be up two pawns and I
mean where are you even moving that
rookie Rook to F7 You're Gonna Play
Knight back to B6 uh the bishop now can
come to this diagonal it's a complete
Massacre if Rook to F6 we can even play
Knight captures and see eight Rook
captures uh Bishop to D7 so there's no
move Hikaru can make here whatever he
makes he's just gonna suffer severe as a
severe material loss uh so yeah a really
really wonderfully done by another
Becker after the spawn to F5 which was
okay probably Hikaru thought uh Bishop
F5 okay I've calculated this loser maybe
Pawn to F5 holds if another Meg does not
play it uh the Perfection but he did he
found Knight captures on C4 uh the
engine even gives it a double
exclamation mark so you know it's a it's
a brilliant move uh and yeah I didn't
show it in the previous video but these
are the uh encounters so bookish
defeated tari in classical we've seen
that game alireza lost
lost the Magnus Crossing in Armageddon
another big defeated Hikaru in
Armageddon and Fabiano Corona defeated
Wesley so in Armageddon and as Hikaru
lost to another back these are the
standings before round nine so uh Fabi
leading with 16 points Hikaru trailing
with 13 and a half points so if Hikaru
beats Fabi In classical and Hikaru will
have the white pieces against Fabian
classical then hikar will win the
tournament if not Fabi is the winner as
he's the only one who can catch up to
him okay gookish he's on 13 points so if
gukesh wins his classical and Fabi loses
his classical but yeah he Fabi loses he
lost the Hikaru so Hikaru is the winner
so unfortunately for Lucas even though
he played a spectacular tournament he's
half a point uh behind of um being able
to time for for first place then you
have Wesley and Anish with 11 and a half
magnets with ten and a half progressing
slowly but progressing Magnus again like
I said after he's lost the Fabian round
one won all of the matches but he won
all of them in Armageddon and sharing
with alireza in seventh place then a
shark there in eighth Notre back with
seven and a half in ninth place and tari
still in last place with 10 points and
I've shown it in the previous video but
also if you haven't seen it the car the
big winners are uh Fabi on plus 13 and a
half in in second place uh Wesley plus
four on each plus three a good Cash Plus
seven uh and he's now a number 13 in the
world absolutely incredible uh and
that's pretty much it another back lost
some points he's on minus eight but
still you know in top 25. uh so yeah uh
that's uh the game and a little bit of
extra info so hope you enjoyed that
we'll see what happens in the final
round should be absolutely incredible uh
I would like to thank David Kimura David
gasparian Ricky Johnson uh
and hydraga for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Norway
chess the final round until it finishes
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day